[تصفيق]
يفجرها هناك خطر امريكي نحونا وبايدن
بامكانه انهاء الحرب خلال خمس دقائق فما
الذي يقصده واردوغان يضع حلا لانضمام
السويد للنيتو ويستغل موقفا اخر للانضمام
للاتحاد الاوروبي والولايات المتحده تعلن
عجزها امام سلاح روسي خطير
والكريم لم يكشف ما فعله
الانقلاب والرئيس الشيشاني ياخذ
وكوريا الشماليه ترضع الطائرات واشنطن
بينما تطلق بيونغي صافرات الانذار وتعلن
حاله التاهب النوويه والسودان للاشتباكات
العنيفه عنوان والاسلحه الثقيله وتدخل على
الخط
معارك التحالفات تشتعل
الحلف والحلفاء هذا يقبل وذاك يرفض طرف
يطلب واخر يقدم المساعدات واطراف اخرى
تستغل الازمات وها هو الرئيس التركي رجب
طيب اردوغان يقول ان انتهاء الصراع في
اوكرانيا في اقرب وقت ممكن بشكل عادل
ودائم سيسهل عمليه انضمامك فماذا لو انضمت
هل سيمنع انضمامها عمليات بوتين من جانبه
رد الرئيس الامريكي في قوله ان اوكرانيا
ليست مستعده بعد للانضمام الى حلف النيتو
مشيرا الى ان الحرب الروسيه داخل الاراضي
الاوكرانيه يجب ان تنتهي قبل ان يتمكن
الحلف من التفكير في اضافه الى صفوفه
واضاف بايدن في لقاء مع محطه سي ان انضمام
اوكرانيا للنيتو الان سيجعل الحلفاء في
حاله مباشره مع روسيا اما حفيد ارطغرل فعد
ليتحدث عن انضمام اخر للنيتو واعلن انه
سيدعم عضويه السويد في النيتو بشرط ان
يعيد الاتحاد الاوروبي اطلاق مفاوضات
انضمام بلاده للتكتل نعم اردوغان يستغل
حاجه اوروبا والغرب لضم السويد ويضع شرط
هل يتم الاستجابه لطلبات الرئيس التركي
اجابه حلف الناتو لم تتاخر واكد امينه
العام انه يؤيد انضمام انقر للاتحاد
الاوروبي تاتي يدي تصريحات قبيل قمه
ثلاثيه برعايه النيتو تضم السويد وانقره
لكن هناك في اوروبا حيث يقف حفيد هتلر
المستشار الالماني الذي رد على اردوغان
بقوله انه لا يوجد هناك علاقه بين انضمام
السويد للنيتو بمساله انضمام تركيا الى
الاتحاد الاوروبي فمن سيخرج رابحا من هذه
معادله برايكم ومن حرب الاحلاف ننتقل الى
الحرب الاوكرانيه حيث اكد رئيس اوكرانيا
ان الرئيس الامريكي بامكانه وقف النزاع
القائم في خمس دقائق ويقصد ان واشنطن
تستطيع ارغام كييف على التفاوض وايقاف
الحرب فيما اشار الى ان كييف تتلقى اشارات
خطيره من سياسيين امريكيين لتقليص
المساعدات العسكريه وذلك بحسب المصدر
والذي نتصفحه امامكم فموقع معروف بدقه
مصادره في تداوله الاخبار العالميه وعلى
صعيد التطورات الميدانيه اعلن الجيش
الاوكراني استعاده السيطره على مرتفعات
رئيسيه حول مدينه باخموت التي تشهد اطول
المعارك على جبهه الشرق وقالت نائبه وزير
الدفاع الاوكراني عن ماليار ان هذا التقدم
يمكن القوات الاوكرانيه من السيطره على
مداخل ومخارج المدينه على قولها هناك عبر
الرئيس الاوكراني عن سعادته بهذه التقدمات
ليقول ان قواتي بلاده اخذت بزمام المبادره
في الهجوم المضاد بعد تباطؤ وفي الاثناء
اعلنت كييف تحرير 14 كيلو مترا مربعا من
سيطره القوات الروسيه الاسبوع الماضي يا
راجل 14 حتى واحده هل يعتبر هذا انجازا
عسكريا بنظركم ليظهر هنا رئيس هيئه اركان
القوات الروسيه
[موسيقى]
منذ تمرد قوات باجنر الشهر الماضي ويكلف
الاستخبارات الروسيه وقياده المجموعه
المشتركه باتخاذ التدابير اللازمه لتعزيز
المنشات من الضربات الجويه بينما اعلن
الرئيس الشيشاني رمضان قدروف نقل قواته
الخاصه في الجيش الروسي المعروفه بقوات
احمد الى بخمه للمشاركه في المعارك
الدائره في محورها لتعويض قوات
وعلى ذكر فاغنر قال الكرملين ان الرئيس
الروسي فلاديمير بوتين التقى قائد
بعد خمسه ايام من التمرد واضاف الكريم ان
بوتين عرض خلال اجتماع امتد ثلاثه ساعات
مع قاده فاجنر وبحضور خمسه عسكريا من
الشركه خيارات للعمل والتوظيف في المجال
العسكري وذكرت الرئاسه الروسيه نقاده
فاجنر اوضح روايتهم لما حدث واكدوا
تاييدهم له وهنا نعود للسؤال مره اخرى هل
عفا بوتين عن بريجوجن التمرد كان خطه
مدبره لحاجه في نفس بوتين وهنا حان الوقت
ايضا ليعاود وزير الدفاع الروسي
ومن ساحه التدريبات وجهها رساله واضحه بان
للمتعاقدين العسكريين او المرتزقه دورا
مهما في حرب روسيا على اوكرانيا ويعتمد
عليهم الجيش الروسي في في جبهات القتال
حيث يجري تدريب الاف المتعاقدين مع الجيش
الروسي ارساليهم الى جبهات القتال
باوكرانيا وها هو
يتفقد تدريبات بنفسه لنعد الى حلف النيتو
مره اخرى حيث نقلت وكاله رويترز عن ثلاثه
الدبلوماسيين ان الدول الاعضاء في حلف
النيتو توصلت الى اتفاق حول خطط دفاعيه
توضح بالتفصيل كيف سيرد الحلف على اي هجوم
الروسي وذلك على الرغم من محاوله تركيا
لعرقله الاتفاق بسبب تضمين قبرص التركيه
داخل خطط الحلف هذه ليشير ذلك الى تحول
كبير اذ ان هذه هي المره الاولى التي يضع
فيها النيتو مثل هذه الخطط منذ نهايه
الحرب البارده قبل ثلاثه عقود وبين هذا
وذاك نحن نعود نحو الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه حيث افادت صحيفه الامريكيه بان
الطور بيد النوويا مس واحدا فقط من نوع
بوسيد الروسي بمقدوره تدمير بضع ولايات
امريكيه مثل نيويورك
وغيرهما مضيفه ان اعتراض ذلك التوربيد
مستحيل عمليا وهذا التصريح الامريكي يشرح
نفسه يا ساده ولا داعي للافاضه ودعونا
ننتقل الى
الاحداث والتطورات
قالت
شقيقه الزعيم الكوري الشمالي ان الطائرات
حربيه لكوريا الشماليه تصدت لطائره تجسس
امريكيه علقت فوق المنطقه الاقتصاديه
الخالصه لبلادها لتطلق كميه تهديدا شديدا
اللهجه بانه سيقع حادث مروع ان تكرر هذا
التحليق حيث تتسلل الطائرات التجسس
الامريكيه بشكل معتاد الى السماء فوق
منطقه المياه الاقتصاديه لكوريا الشماليه
وفق تعبيرها ومن جهه اخرى ندد الشماليه
بمقاله انه سعي من الولايات المتحده لجلب
غواصه صواريخ باليستيه تعمل بالطاقه
النوويه الى مياه قريبه من شبه الجزيره
الكوريه وحذرت من ان هذه الخطوه تؤدي الى
وضع يجعل الصراع النوويه اقرب الى الواقع
عصبر اعلنت اذاعه الجيش الاسرائيلي بان
قوات الجيش قتلت فلسطينيا حاول تفجير عبوه
ناسفه شمال الضفه الغربيه اشتباكات عنيفه
باستخدام الاسلحه الثقيلين اندلعت بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع في
منطقه الكلاكله الجنوبيه العاصمه الخرطوم
بينما دوله انفجارات متتاليه سمعت جنوبيه
مدينه ام درمان وغربي الخرطوم اضافه
لتبادل اطلاق نار من اسلحه ثقيله بين
الجيش السوداني وقوات الدعم السريع بمدينه
الابيض غربي السودان
[موسيقى]